[Musique]
toute l'inspiration du village même
thème
puis son sens et son essence dans la
spiritualité dans l'islam donne c'est
grâce à cette belle religion en fait qui
nous invite à l'amour du partage au
travail à la réflexion sur
l'amélioration des conditions de vie
notre milieu en adéquation et en
harmonie avec la nature
[Musique]
jc la centrale à gaza la bagarre qui est
responsable de la production qui gère la
production
[Musique]
leschi
et
l'un des objectifs que les créer une
économie locale dynamique avec des
activités économiques avec voilà des
activités vraiment intéressantes à faire
au lieu de forcément quitter ici pour
aller en ville pour chercher du travail
[Musique]
je suis
g
et
[Musique]
j'suis
et
m
il
[Musique]